first time I saw Jimmy was 1965 Little
Richard is the star of the bill after
the show he is screaming you
[__] don't you ever play guitar
with your teeth again you mother and it
was Jimmy great advice don't you use
those teeth young
[Music]
man how close did you come to forming
that super group with Jimmy Hendrick
didn't he approach you after the Beatles
broke up he did not write a letter to
you and said I want to get together with
you well I never received it you might
have done it I don't know man I mean you
know there's lots of what if you know I
certainly love Jimmy I certainly was one
of the first people to see him in London
and it was mindblowing you know oh you
were there you were part of that crowd
huh I was was you clapped in all listen
to this I was in a club late at night
called The Bag of Nails actually where
I'm at Linda and uh you just go in there
and it was empty yeah and I just heard
this sort of clunking clicking a little
stage in the corner and I heard a sort
of of like a loud Jack plug being
plugged into somebody was plugging a
guitar into an amp but a big amp and it
was you know and I just thought H that
then just sort of turned away and talked
who I was talking and then it was Jimmy
and nol and Mitch it was the Jimmy Henry
experience in the corner no one had
heard him and he did his whole act for
virtually no one in the Club his act at
the time was probably what we knew as
the Jimmy Hendrick experience album The
with purple haze and all that stuff yeah
he's doing all that stuff and I'm just
how far into how far into his set do you
suddenly go wait a second I hear
something the first minute really the
first second he starts singing and
playing were you there with Clapton as
the leg this was just kind of me with a
couple of friends late night hardly
anyone in the club I think that was a
Friday night and on the Tuesday night
the word had got out and now the club
was steaming and packed for this new God
in town I saw jimmi Hendricks when I was
14 how do you do that you just you buy a
ticket to a show and you get I bought a
ticket he played in Newcastle before he
made it actually before he had his first
hit in England which was Hey Joe right
he played the club of Goog go in
Newcastle and I I must have been 15 how
did you know to go to that I mean uh
just on the you know you just on the
grap Vine you hear what's cool did it
blow your mind could it could it have
been debilitating when you see a guy
who's that proficient at guitar and
writing music could you say to yourself
I could never [__] do this I thought
I was seeing a martian I mean there were
very few black people in in Newcastle
right he played left-handed Fender
guitar with his hair and the clothes and
just freak me out yeah when you see a
guy like that is it like with a painter
do you go home and try to emulate him
right away do you say I've got to figure
out how he does this no the lesson was
that you can be a rock star and a
virtuoso at the same time because he was
clearly first time I saw Jimmy was
1965 at the sup sales Easter show at the
Paramount Theater in New York square
kiding me that's crazy wait Listen to
This Little Richard is the star of the
bill and we watched him I mean he was
kickass I mean Little Richard is
phenomenal right Great Entertaining one
day after the show he comes out he is
screaming you [__] don't you
ever play guitar with your teeth again
you mother and it was Jimmy advice don't
you use those teeth young man but then
when you were in England I guess and all
these McCartney's there and Lenin and
all that all these guys who you know
you're all there to what P you had heard
about him oh yeah his reputation you
know Eric U Clapton and and particularly
Pete towns had had been spreading the
word about this new kid from America and
that you better come and watch this kid
cuz this is something special it was
almost like going to school right yes
for for guitar players yeah Clapton said
that night was so uh it was almost
detrimental to him he felt like he
wanted to put down his guitar after he
saw jimmi Hendrick well thank God he
didn't no of course not but but but was
that he was that mind-blowing why was it
so mindblowing because there was an
incredible energy and there was only
three of them in the experience it was
only Mitch Mitchell on drums and NL
reading on bass were Mitch and NL good
musicians Mitch was an incredible
drummer I don't think that NL would
played bass before he joined the
experience that's what I've always heard
and and so and on the albums Jimmy
played all the instruments that's what
I've heard I still think that uh that no
played bass and Mitch very much played
drums cuz Mitch Mitchell came to live
with me in in my apartment he was you
know he didn't you know they were just
catching fire and he didn't have any
place to live so come over to live with
me so then I I I was able to hang out
with Mitch and hang out with Jimmy let
me tell you something nobody in the
world could beat Jimmy Hendrick at risk
you know the board risk risk yeah he'd
play Risk on acid
you never stood a chance I always have
this thought like if jimmi Hendricks had
lived would he have burned out or would
he have been still like one of the the
great rock act I I I tend to believe
that he would still have been one of the
great Rock acts because he was so he was
so ahead of his time are you wearing a
jimmi Hendricks t-shirt yeah I was just
talking to Graham Nash about jimmi
Hendricks one of the greats oh Jimmy
Hendricks belongs with Bach Beethoven
and all the greatest musicians in
history when you were serving when you
were in na SE I bet you part of your
soundtrack was Jimmy Hendrick
I actually saw Jimmy 1970 San Diego
concert just months before he died is
that right you were just in the audience
one of the fans yeah Jimmy Hendricks was
he with the experience at that point uh
no he was the experience had broken up
he was he he had the uh uh he had uh uh
that Trio the the the the Jazz thing
going on no no no no he was doing his
real stuff he just uh he had Buddy Miles
I think on drums and he had he had uh
broke woken up the experience by he do
the classics like purple ha all of them
he did them all absolutely are you
kidding and the good part was if you
were in the military you got discount on
your tickets is that right oh yeah were
you in the military when you saw Jimmy
Hendrick yes oh no kidding in fact when
I saw Jimmy I was going through SEAL
training it's one of the great memories
I have who's the greatest guitar was it
was it Hendrick is that the boring
answer I mean that's I mean he was he
was first of all he was so humble you
know but there's so many great
you know there's so many greats mean I
mean what's what's so delightful about
Hendrick it was sort of like first of
all it's sort of astounding I don't
understand what he was doing but it um
his feel and his Groove was so great but
also he
was sort of allowing all this magic of
of his Brilliance to shine and he was
sort of fearless and and you know that's
part of what made him so great is is
that will you know he wasn't
not every step was careful not every it
was like this boldness this freedom of
uh you know he he didn't get up on stage
and play a solo that he perfected he got
up on stage and just was like this is
what I got today you know and and that's
unbelievable you know some licks that he
would repeat because they're part of the
song but then he would could just fly
and that's a crazy courage who was your
Guitar Hero growing up oh geez I had a
lot of great guitar here HRI Hendrick
was truly One of a Kind what was it it
just it was no he made it look so easy
you he just had everything he was just a
you know he was a great player and and
the music of the at the at that time I
mean you hear when I first heard Purple
Haze you go hey whoa It's the sound it's
it's a life Cher yeah it's a life
changer when that album came out that I
you experience you know I mean I saved
up my pocket money I said going that's
that's me what an album yeah
this is crazy Joe was a a football
player and what was it you heard
Hendrick and you said [__] I want to
play the guitar no I'd been into uh
Jimmy's records my my older siblings
were playing all the stuff and I fell in
love with the music like mid and late
60s and I just became a Hendrick fan
since '
67 and uh but I wasn't really thinking
about playing guitar I'd been a drummer
for about three years and then kind of
gave it up and then uh yeah I was on the
football team I was on the fitness team
I was on the track team you know uh I'm
not sure I was very good football player
I was kind of small but um yeah I was
all suited up and a teammate came out
right as we were walking on the track
and and said yeah that guy Hendrick you
like he's dead you know and so I just
turned around walked into the coach's
office and said I'm quitting football
I'm going to dedicate my life to playing
guitar the great guitar players are the
ones that come out with clear concise
notes in other words it's there's
nothing mushy about it it's like that's
the note and it's clean is that what
we're going for yeah yeah yeah any
guitar player wants to play clean you
know and some guys Stevie Ray vom was
really noisy he shook it you know his
vibr was so hard it'd be go you know it
made noises but that was kind of cool
you know I mean on the blues but in
general you're trying to you're trying
to play a clean lick you know and that's
white guys like Joe and Eddie and you
know even hendrickx was noisy too though
you got to admit oh yeah I mean but that
was back in the day those guys had I
mean compared to what we have today it
was primitive equipment you know keep Jo
show me an example show me an example
what what sami's talking about what does
a noisy Hendrix lick sound like what is
show show me something noisy that
Hendrick did well he was doing a lot of
pushing and pulling so pushing and
pulling would be like
[Music]
uh I mean I've cleaned it up so I don't
know if I can do it but when you when
you're pushing it you're pushing the
strings and pulling them and and uh you
know doing
all kind of stuff you don't know what
you're going to get today I've got this
thing here so I can
go I just keep going you know but Jimmy
didn't have those things he'd have to
turn the amp up and go hump the speakers
you know to get that kind of
wow wow I mean what amazing they really
they they laid the groundwork you know
Jimmy he just rewrote the book for the
electric guitar he really did and and
the thing is he could improvise like a
like a jazz musician he was like cold
train and Miles inside of a guitar
player so together with all that
electric stuff he he had a mind to solo
just like one of the greatest uh horn
players or piano players so that was was
the big difference there how did you
become good friends with jimmi Hendrick
how did you come to know him by being
easy and good friendly how do you run
into a Jimmy Hendrick you were on the
scene early on you're both actually I
met him uh he was going on tour with the
monkeys and with the monkeys with the
monkeys and was he opening for this this
is going to last about two weeks Jim and
uh but but we went out to my house and
played for two days you no kidding you
and Jimmy yeah we see a great guitar
player the best the best is it true that
you were being managed by someone who
got so insecure Jimmy sent word to your
manager that he wanted you to be in the
Jimmy Hendrick experience that you would
play guitar it wasn't no reading it was
you and your manager did not tell you of
this because he was afraid you'd leave
Buffalo Springfield true or false it
wasn't Buffalo Springfield it was CSN it
Cs and I was in Hawaii nursing a broken
wrist which would have been ready in a
couple of weeks but uh they wanted me to
come play come play bass until we found
a new Bas player but we Jimmy and I had
been thinking about this you know over
in England for a while and um they
didn't pass on the message I've spent a
lot of time being manipulated back into
csncs wow it's unbelievable right would
you have done that would you have been a
member of jimmi Hendrick's band had he
uh gotten word to you hell yes you would
have what a collaboration that you did
collaborate with him though right hell
yes is a great disappointment to you
that you never got to record that album
with Jimmy Hendrick that you guys were
going to collaborate is that a great
disappointment in your life the one did
you ever meet Hendrick yeah oh you did
did you ever get to play with him uh not
live not live backstage you went
backstage where was this uh Youngstown
Ohio back in the early 70s so okay and
you're what doing a concert yeah James
Gang concert at that point James Gang
Hendrick in uh in sliding the Family
Stone all on the same bill remember in
those days wow yeah you had three
Headliners on a show and who opened that
show uh we did the James gang yeah
unbelievable what a show so Hendrick is
backstage and what happened you go he's
backstage we we're in in a like a
uh dressing room which is like where a
hockey team changes or something you
know glamorous that so yeah we finished
in and we're in the same dressing room
so uh he's sit playing his guitar and I
come in with mine right and uh and you
have a jam session so to speak a little
bit yeah I I showed him my guitar and he
showed me his do you get intimidated by
a guy like that nah he was a wonderful
guy of course I'm intimidated by his
talent I mean by him he he had an aura I
mean he had feathers on I mean it was
terrifying well you know you talk about
that I read that Clapton and a bunch of
other guys at the time who were
considered top guitarists all went to
see Jimmy Hendricks when he first came
on the scene they went to a club and
they all looked at each other and they
went [__] we don't even like really play
the GU what are we doing that was the
famous story generally thought by the
community yeah what the hell are we
doing did you feel that way yeah you did
when you played with when you played
with him did he say oh wow Joe maybe we
should get together in a studio and do
something together or never got that far
no I never got that far but uh he showed
me his guitar and I I saw I paid
attention to what how the heavy strings
light strings right how high are the
strings what's the action cuz he was a
tough one you know cuz he was
left-handed so everything was backwards
that's why he sounded like that none of
us right-handed guitar players could do
what he was doing was he playing a lefty
guitar no he was playing a right-handed
guitar with his upside down oh wow
that's why he sounded like that you and
that's why we couldn't Crack the Code oh
my God that's fascinating
that's why we were all hitting ourselves
in the head but that's why you're a
great guitar player because you're a
student sitting with Jimmy Hendricks
it's a master class yeah wow even if
it's three or four minutes and I had
alst Paul and and he looked at that and
uh he was really really nice and and
just a a good guy when I read about you
you guys and your early beginnings and
stuff like Billy you were you were
opening for Jimmy Hendrick yeah and you
credit Hendrick with your guitar style
you said you learned a lot from him yes
indeed somehow we got picked up early on
yeah and uh they were they were I
wouldn't say Straight Shooters they were
but they weren't Shooters at that point
the experience Hendricks and the
experience yeah yeah and you know what
Jimmy was doing with that guitar was was
crazy just yeah the inventors never
dreamed that that you know he was doing
things that they said well they they
didn't say he can't do it he just
started doing it where were you when you
first saw him was it was it my blowing
yeah he was scary and uh there is one
interesting aside uh he saw to it I
remember seeing this uh console record
player being taken into the room Night
by night and uh he saw to it that I had
a room across the hall and he called me
in and he said hey yeah what do what do
you think about this and he was playing
and learning by listening to a Jeff Beck
Jeff Beck's first record he was
listening to Beck but isn't that crazy
like he had I don't think he had a
guitar lesson in his life or he was a
true svant in a sense I mean he really
was a genius yeah man and so what was
the deal for you you would just sit
there and watch him play and pick up
technique he said do you know this and I
said no but keep on I want to know this
and could you actually mimic some of the
things that he was doing yeah he taught
me the
the you foxy lady wow that's really uh
incredible I had always heard a rumor
when you talk about Jimmy Hendricks in
the experience that his B player nol
reading who I knew was not really a bass
player that he was not very good is that
is that fair to say he was the I guess
the bottom end glue that worked but he
fancied himself more of a truly he was a
guitarist and and did did Jimmy play
bass on those albums or did nol play
bass on those albums nol played he did
on the early the first two oh all right
cuz it's an unfair rap that he always
got right yeah yeah did you know Jimmy
Hendricks uh I met him at uh Monteray
pop oh no kidding in fact we jammed
together no kidding if you could call if
you me playing me trying to keep up with
him he plays such a different style that
you he's all over the place he was
extraordinarily gifted guitarist that's
not not a new piece of news but that's
where I met him I saw that show where he
set his guitar on fire what did you make
it that I thought it was an incredible
Act of Showmanship talk about mon to Ray
pop when you guys uh played you flipped
a coin with Jimmy Hendrick and you said
whoever wins the coin toss I guess we'll
go on first that's how you determine and
the who won the coin toss so you guys
got to go on First and that's good
because you probably just want to get
out of there right well it wasn't just
that unknown to most people Jimmy
actually all that guitar smashing and
all that stuff in the speakers he had
kind of copied that from Pete he did
that was Pete's show in 1964 65 Jimmy
came over and saw it and just took the
whole thing took it to a different level
he did but he did take that from that
was all Pete's show and of course we
were going if he goes on before us he's
done sh right well the thing was Pete
was the guy who used to smash his guitar
and wreck it and and and Jimmy said uhoh
I got to outdo him so he lit his guitar
on fire at Monterey and then at
Woodstock of course he lit his fire L
his guitar on fire and in a way he got
known for that it had to irritate you a
little bit it did it did get up am those
a bit but anyway we won we won the the
the TOs and we went on First and uh and
sadly for Jimmy by the time he got on
you know the last microphone was nearly
broken if you watch the film of Monteray
cuz it's all borrowed equipment and you
can see people rushing on to save
microphones Dr it's so great I just love
it oh man it it's so crazy I was
thinking about Jimmy Hendrick like what
the hell would he be doing now you
wonder would he would he just be like
completely out of it or or would he have
continue to make great music he just
never know with people some people he
doing Jazz he was he was really getting
into jazz when he he was moving in that
direction really moving in that
direction I know and Jimmy was very
quiet very very philosophical very
poetic um maybe he would have been a
poet a jazz poet maybe who knows he's
such a shame right
yeah